DC releases comic with pregnant Joker
who birthes a son it's real look at this
Jasper Bell says today DC released a
comic in which the Joker becomes
pregnant and gives birth to a mud
monster who transforms into a child
version of himself who he adopts as his
son I don't know how much longer I can
do this well I don't know though like is
it really that bad that the Joker has a
mud baby that turns into a little Joker
like is it just a mud baby is it
officially a mud baby it literally says
oh it says yeah he gives birth to a mud
monster yeah out of his you know what
out of his butt I guess it says it's uh
it's on the it's that's what that's what
you guys so so uh I don't know if I'm
supposed to be mad about this it's like
it's a comic and it's weird and it's
stupid it has people talking about it I
think it's it's it's done for Pure
marketing purposes just to have some
individuals freak out about it just so
they could sell more comic books I think
they understand this more than ever now
and they have us talking about it right
yeah apparently oh what we're gonna say
I don't think anybody's buying this
comic book uh because they did this I
don't think it's good marketing I think
they're doing it because it's satanic
it's absolutely evil that's why they
keep trying to confuse the children I
saw you got the book right over there
genderqueer yeah they put that in
kindergarten libraries it's got pictures
of family financial yeah yeah it's got
pictures of man on man boy on boy child
on child graphic picture pictures and
that's what they want to teach to kids
they're trying to take this generation
and and you know the lgbtq they want to
add a p they want to add a p which
stands for pedophile that's what these
people are trying to put into the
culture yeah that lgbtq sounds I think a
little too far because lesbians are not
queer or I don't think so unless the
definition has changed they're not trans
so T and L aren't the same thing YT
defines a different thing it defines an
assignment of identity not even like of
what attraction you have right like so
to believe so yeah it's t for
transsexual so it's like not an L where
is L G and B I'll refer to like the way
you are to the rest of the world I want
I want to give you guys a little context
of the Joker got pregnant or is that I
have it right here how did he get
pregnant
Zatanna is a magic Caster who curses him
trying to sterilize him because he was
trying to hook up with her but he falls
into mud and accidentally becomes
pregnant I guess yeah she says you can
never procreate with someone else so he
does it with himself I guess
he wakes up and uh there he is like
getting out of bed it's like here's a
joker and they're like oh hey look
you're pregnant
and then here's what is this is this uh
Atomic Skull it's Dr phosphorus atomic
skull never even finished pre-med
this seems like it's supposed to be a
joke and then oh he barfs it doesn't
come out of his butt and then it is okay
look apparently I didn't I didn't know
that but the phrase mud baby is
offensive or something it's meant to be
a slur is that what it is I think that's
a racist term is what they say well he
gives birth to a baby that is made of
mud like so they did that and then the
baby turns into a little Joker I guess
for some reason so it sounds more like
indigestion than uh a birthing process
but if they're going to tell us he was
pregnant that's part of the storyline
who's to say it's why why did the
audience for this I don't know what else
they're trying to create story they're
trying to make and create they have so
much money and they're able to take such
a loss that they just do the weirdest
stuff and hope that people start to get
upset well look look I mean to be honest
a lot of stuff is stagnant culture is
just repetitious it's a new Spider-Man
the same stories over and over and over
again so that's why I'm kind of like I
don't know he he vomits Up Mud that
turns into a baby Joker I don't know if
I'm complaining about that it's not it's
not like some weird it's just a weird
story whatever God help us it did I mean
so it didn't come out of his took us no
he barfs it up he barfs up a baby I get
how you give birth I I bet when they
were writing it they were like we can't
have them crap it out you know yeah
though they should have or burst out of
his stomach it's a little too graphic
yeah and then they're good and then they
try to kill it I guess that's the plan
they're like oh no no that's a die I
don't know man is this is this get what
go broke or uh I don't know
it's not it's yeah it is it's like a
form of impact investment these
corporations take the your ESG money
with BlackRock and they'll invested in
things that they want to happen on Earth
regardless of if there's going to be a
profit and they think that that the
profit will be that you get to live in a
world that we want you to live that's
good for you uh and that's the same
thing what they're doing they're not
doing this to make money they're doing
this to change culture and take a hit on
their finances it's impact they're doing
it for impact they're trying to lose
money or they're willing to lose money
to change culture i I don't know DC lost
a lot of money uh I think they just
stopped Batgirl uh Wonder Woman
Superwoman all of those kind of shows I
think we're we're canceled because they
were absolute crap and people are like
there's no way we're going to be
watching any of this nonsense so I think
culturally we are at a very interesting
moment where I think there is a bigger
pushback against this larger agenda
against this larger nonsense which is
absolutely nonsensical which of course
these big multinational corporations
don't actually care about they're just
trying to use it as a way to of course
indoctrinate people and gain some money
uh I think money is an incentive here I
think they don't care but I think uh you
know with the way that DC has been
handling themselves over the past few
months I don't think this was deliberate
I think this was just someone trying to
be maybe edgy trying to get people to
talk about it trying to get some
interest there and doing something
different for uh for finally other than
regurgitating an old story and just
repackaging it with the right labels and
personalities and and uh you know cues
this is why the right needs to make our
own stuff John De La Rose an amazing
writer writes right-wing comic books it
has none of this woke disgusting crap
and this stuff is getting into the
comics the movies and the video games
that's why we made the fake news turkey
shoot writtenhousegame.com because even
Grand Theft Auto they're trying to turn
that into some kind of feminist game we
need right so many things
writtenhousegame.com the fake news
turkey shoot if you don't support
right-wing culture you're going to get
more Joker puking out a baby so the game
is fun by the way that we just made the
first level free on rittenhousegame.com
they're making GTA like you get to be a
woman because the big complaint everyone
had was that they wanted to be a woman
as they went around committing crimes
and murdering people and all that stuff
I guess it's like a female protagonist
for the first time I wonder if they're
gonna have male prostitutes in there too
like okay here
I guess here's the issue I see with all
of this woke culture stuff is like
why is it that rom-coms are are
considered to be like movies for women
why is it that action Flex our movies
for men is it because they naturally
just tend towards those things guys
don't want to watch rom-coms they want
to see Bruce Willis jump out of a
skyscraper again for like the 18th time
women don't want to watch a guy jump out
of a skyscraper for the 18th time but
sometimes do especially if they're
hanging out with their friends and it's
a fun entertaining flick but like what
they try to do
they tried doing a a rom-com with only
men that Bros movie where they're all
gay and it bombs and they had in that
movie jokes about gay orgies and I'm
like here's the thing dude there's not
enough people who understand the context
of that humor to understand why it's
funny that there's a gay orgy happening
like what the joke is and then they put
women in masculine roles and give them
male motivations and wonder why these
movies are struggling I thought Wonder
Woman was good because she was strong
you know Wonder Woman Diana but uh she
actually had some like motherly
qualities like the the debate between
her and Chris Pine's character was like
a pragmatist versus a realist was like a
mother versus a father it worked pretty
well but then they try and just make
films where it's a female with male
goals take a look at Hunger Games
it was a Katniss Everdeen female action
hero whose motivation was to protect her
family but she very much was trying to
stay away from the conflict it was it
was it was a very different kind of
narrative she didn't want to be involved
she didn't want the war just leave me
alone leave my family alone and they
force her into the conflict where
typically with a male character it's
like they're thrust into Adventure but
then you end up with these weird we're
going to make a movie we're gonna make
the main character who's actually in the
in the in the book A man into a woman
and then they wonder why these things
don't work we need right wing movies too
that's why I'm also I'm also putting out
a film anti-white movie we're talking
about all the disgusting things the
media is trying to push divide Society
if we don't make right wing films if we
don't make things everybody talks about
you know promote right-wing culture
somebody's got to do it we got to make
this stuff anti-whitemovie.com we have
to actually get things going I know Tim
is Tim is putting out his skateboards I
saw the the logo we have to make right
wing things and people say you know Matt
Brainerd loves to talk about economic
nationalism and that's what we need we
need people that actually build things
and the right has to support it I want
to even just make the best stuff the
best art on Earth yeah that little kids
that don't understand politics are drawn
to so you get them before they get
indoctrinated and then you can be like
teaching them about kindness and
Christian you know whatever philosophy
this is the thing the woke cult
struggles with philosophy the if if you
actually understood if I'll put it this
way I don't think you could take a woke
person have them go up into the
mountains with some like Yogi Monk and
meditate and have them stay woke I think
if people start to understand Concepts
about nature reality God these ideas
around it they they say okay those ideas
don't work maybe some of these people
don't have the capabilities that they
struggle with it but I think with with
the woke cult a lack of philosophical
understanding is what drives a lot of
them being locked into the cult I used
to laugh at I might have brought this up
on the show uh Mr Rogers did you ever
watch that show he's so nice yeah and I
would my parents would tell me you're
you're okay just as who you are it's
okay to be you even if it feels weird
even if it's you're sad and you're
crying they're mean to you it's okay and
so I saw it as redundant I'd see Mr
Rogers say that same kind of stuff and I
was like oh this is boring but I think
other kids now I'm realizing they didn't
have parents like me some of them didn't
have parents at all and they weren't
told they're okay being who they are and
so now they're looking to find a way to
become okay and we need people like that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time